Yuval Noah Harari.
Welcome back to the program.
It's good to be here. Thank you.
So we speak on a day where there's been
a terrorist attack,
some kind of attack
that details are coming in, in Jerusalem.
It's a long time
since we've seen this kind of thing.
Very sadly,
a young Israeli Canadian, a 16 year
old, has been killed.
And there are reports
that a Palestinian was killed yesterday.
Why do you think this is happening
now after such a long time?
I don't know.
I can't get
into the minds of the terrorists
behind it.
It's a very painful day,
especially as it seems
that they targeted
young people on purpose.
That they deliberately chose to attack.
I mean, many of the of the kids,
not just the kid
that was killed,
but also if the injured
are kids on the way to school,
And this was deliberate.
And it's you know,
you can't really get into
the mind of people
who knowingly do something like that.
And as we were just discussing,
this terrible mass
shooting of a different sort in
the United States has just happened.
But you're in Israel,
the eternally unresolved situation.
What do you think it will take
to actually end this cycle of violence?
I know that's way above my pay grade.
I you know, basically
it's a problem of motivation.
It seems that we have reached a point
when many people, even
maybe most people on both sides
just don't have the motivation
to solve this.
This is a political problem
solving, not like mathematical problems
in mathematics.
You have problems
that you can really prove.
They have no solution
This problem has no solution.
There is no such thing in politics.
All political problems have solutions.
It all depends on how much motivation
people have.
And unfortunately,
we are in a time
when they have no motivation.
And does it
depend on the structural situation?
I mean, we we we said that it's
almost like Back to the Future with this
new Israeli leadership,
Benjamin Netanyahu is bound to be
made Prime Minister and in his coalition.
You know,
it just keeps going further
and further to the extreme.
And this is the most extreme
anybody has seen.
I just want to read you a little bit
about some of the names
which are causing a lot of anxiety
among your biggest allies,
for instance, in the United States.
You've got you know, Itamar Ben-gvir.
He has been convicted
for inciting anti-Arab racism,
supporting terrorism.
Until recently,
he was deemed
even too extreme for government.
There's another one, Smotrich,
who has wanted to be defense minister
and the U.S.
has made it known that they don't
they won't accept that.
You know,
and he is very, very, very hard line.
Some of them are openly homophobic.
They won't shake hands with women
They say the Torah has to rule.
They want to annex
the whole of the West Bank.
What is going on here?
I think one of the key things is that
a lot of the Israeli public
has gradually switched from a belief
in the two-State solution
to at least
an implicit belief
in the three classes solution.
That you have just one country
between the Jordan River
and the Mediterranean
with three classes of people
living there, Jews
who have all the rights,
some Arabs who some rights,
and other Arabs
who have very little or no rights.
And this is increasingly
the situation on the ground.
also the aspiration
or the mindset
of even people in the government.
And this is extremely worrying.
But this is what is happening.
Well, I've never heard you sound so
fatalistic.
You even think
climate change can be mitigated No.
Also this, again,
it goes back to the issue of motivation.
It's not that the
conflict has reached a point
when this is the only solution possible.
It's we've reached a point
when this is the preferred solution
or the preferred situation
for at least
some of the Israeli public
and also some of the Israeli government
or future government members.
This is not deterministic.
It's not written in the stars
or anywhere else.
It's a human choice.
I hope that
people will make different choices, but
that's that's
it's we have to,
first of all, acknowledge
what is the reality
before
we can think of ways of improving it.
So I wonder if that leads me
to turn to your new book.
I mean, I have it here.
It's an amazing book.
We don't usually see your books
like Sapiens
and the others
with this kind of childlike cover.
And of course, behind you,
you have an image from from the book.
So the question and it's called,
you know, Unstoppable US
How Humans Took Over the World.
It's your
history lesson
and civics lesson for young people.
In view of what
we've just been talking about,
motivation and understanding.
What do you think
telling kids will do to shape the future?
I think in the long term, this is the key
because how kids view the world.
This is how they later view
the world as adults.
It's
you can change your minds afterwards.
But it's very difficult
to unlearn
what you have learned as a young person.
If you were raised believing
that, for instance,
your people
is superior
to other people
or superior to everybody else.
And this is what you have been fed for
many years.
It's later on.
It's very difficult to change that.
And unfortunately, we see it again.
It's not an Israeli phenomenon.
We see it in many countries
around the world,
in many people,
many nations around the world.
They raise their young people
on this kind of view.
That we are better than everybody else.
Our interests are more important
than those of of everybody else.
And
unfortunately, this leads
today to an existential crisis
for humankind,
because this kind of thinking
of course, for thousands of years
has led to wars
and prosecutions and so forth.
But now we are facing
some existential global problems,
like climate change
or like the rise of
of artificial intelligence,
which cannot be solved
unless you cooperate
with with the other people in the world.
And these people have this mindset
that we are superior to everybody
and that only our interests matter
Then cooperation is almost impossible.
So do you feel that
you lack that in your primary education?
Yeah, I think that when I grew up
I took it for granted that
Jews are better than everybody else
and that we are more important
than everybody else.
And it took me a lot of years
to realize that actually
this is not necessarily true.
And while it's a lovely, colorful book
full of images and pictures
that will appeal to young people,
it doesn't shy away, as you've been
you've been saying, from very,
very important issues
like climate change.
And and you say,
and I want you to talk a little bit
about this,
because, again, this is a big issue
that not only.
Well,
it seems that
the world should be motivated
and have the political will.
But clearly,
as we've just seen in Sharm el-Sheikh,
they couldn't even get to an agreement
on the big issue
climate, you know,
emissions and and the greenhouse gases
and fossil fuels.
What are you saying to give people hope,
particularly the capitalist world.
But one thing you should be very clear
is that humanity has the power to prevent
catastrophic climate change.
It's completely on us.
It's not an inevitable natural disaster.
We have the scientific knowledge.
We also have the economic resources.
It's estimated that we see if we invest
about 2% of global GDP,
in developing the right technology
and infrastructure, we can prevent
catastrophic climate change.
Now, 2% of global GDP is a lot of money,
but it's completely feasible.
It's what politicians do all the time,
shifting resources from here to there.
Again, it's a question of motivation.
Do people have the political motivation
to do it?
And also,
you know,
we now see the World Cup in Qatar.
And for me, the World Cup, despite
all the criticism
it's is a very positive sign
that, look,
people can agree on something globally.
You know,
with all the criticism that we hear
about globalism,
if you like the World Cup.
You're a globalist
because the World Cup is really globalism
in action.
Globalism doesn't mean the establishment
of some dictatorial global government
forces us to do things we don't want.
It seemed to means
that different countries
can reach agreement on common rules
of how to behave.
You know,
for Brazil to play football
against Germany,
first of all, Brazilians
and Germans need to agree
on some common rules.
Doesn't mean they are not patriotic.
It doesn't mean they still cheer
the national team.
They are still fiercely patriotic.
But this patriotism can go hand-in-hand
with agreeing with the other countries
on common rules.
And this should be the basis
for how we approach other problems.
Like climate change.
Like global inequality. Like I.